I think it's gross that the women who
are clearly not attracted to Leonardo
DiCaprio because he is very not
attractive or just doing it very clearly
for his money now with Madonna dating
toy boys we can all assume that she's
not all there anyway because she keeps
showing us pictures of her bum and her
face now looks like a loaf of Wolverton
what do you think is it any of any of
our businesses I find the Madonna thing
a total cringe yeah uh but I also find
it's slightly cringy DiCaprio that it's
all the women are always very young it's
like well really I feel like your own
Angels what do they talk about I find
DiCaprio creepy actually this yeah
with people you know easily young enough
to be his uh you know his daughter or in
some cases probably he's granddaughter
it's perfectly lost if he likes to go
out with younger women he's a single guy
you're quite right there might be some
double standards with me because I've
criticized you for having a pop-up
Madonna be before maybe we should get
Madonna and DiCaprio together and then
we'll just solve all the problems she's
about 35 years too old